they are nestled
in the final frontier countless worlds
scattered throughout countless galaxies
challenge the notion
that we are alone in the universe
[Music]
exoplanets are worlds that exist outside
of our solar system
also known as extrasolar planets these
bodies often orbit their own stars with
some
being a part of entire planetary systems
exoplanets are made of the same elements
as the worlds in our solar system
and based on their composition and
structures are just as diverse
some known as giant or neptune-like
planets
are large gaseous worlds
other gas giants called hot jupiters
closely orbit their stars causing the
planets to have high
surface temperatures another category of
exoplanets consists
of super earths smaller than the gas
giants
but larger than earth super earths are
terrestrial and made primarily of rocky
or icy material
the final category includes earth
analogs
much as their name implies earth analogs
are similar to earth
in various ways including size
composition
and distance to their home star
exoplanets are difficult to detect
directly
mostly because they are outshined by the
stars they orbit
to circumvent this about five primary
methods have been developed to find
these planetary bodies
including radial velocity in which a
planet causes a star to wobble
direct imaging where the glare of stars
is blocked in order to see objects
nearby astrometry which
observes the star's movements in
relation to nearby stars
gravitational microlensing which
observes the light of a star
being bent by a planet's gravitational
pull
and the most prolific form of finding
exoplanets
transit the method in which a planet
passes between its star and earth
thereby dimming its star's light
[Music]
scientists have suspected the existence
of worlds outside of our solar system
for thousands of years but the first
confirmed existence of an exoplanet
orbiting a sun-like star only occurred
in 1995.
ever since about 4 000 exoplanets have
been confirmed
by multiple discovery methods with about
3
000 more awaiting verification
according to one theory at least one
exoplanet orbits
each star in the milky way this would
place the exoplanet count in our local
galaxy
to about 1 trillion
the search for exoplanets continues not
just to create a catalog of known worlds
but also to see if life may exist
elsewhere in the universe
astrobiologists closely study the size
composition and location of exoplanets
relative to their stars
to see the likelihood of organisms
thriving in an environment other than
earth
who knows what discoveries these new
worlds could bring
[Music]
you